in den letzten wochen habe ich bereits
einmal das günstigste hotel deutschlands
und das teuerste hotel deutschen und
getestet größer schneller weiter auch im
hotel business ist das eine sache die
man immer wieder sieht es muss teuer
sein es muss luxuriös sein aber wie
sieht's aus wenn man einfach mal ein
paar abstriche macht und das kleinste
hotel deutschlands testet
nicht wundern ich komme direkt aus dem
anderen video deswegen habe ich dieses
outfit noch an ich bin jetzt beim
kleinsten hotel deutschlands und ganz
besonders interessiert mich wo macht man
abstriche wenn man so ein kleines zimmer
hat oder ist es vielleicht sogar gut
sich mal ein bisschen zu verkleinern und
vielleicht kommt gar nicht immer auf die
größe an
den rhein und finden das gemeinsam
heraus
ich hätte das kleinste zimmer gerufen
[Musik]
ok herzlich willkommen in dem kleinsten
hotelzimmer deutschland
aber kurz vorweg wo bin ich überhaupt
das kleinste hotelzimmer deutschlands
finden wir mitten in berlin zwei meter
lang 1 meter breit und 1 20 hoch das
sind die maße des zimmers und dadurch
ein verdienter platz eins als kleinstes
hotelzimmer deutschlands was hier
angekommen bin die tür nicht vernünftig
zu das ist kein witz
okay okay
alles was sie hier seht ist quasi das
hotel zwar ich weiß gar nicht so richtig
was ich zeigen soll aber wir fangen
einfach mal vorne an eine tür bei der
ich gerade schon probleme hatte sie auf
und zu machen aber ich habe
herausgefunden dass hier ein knopf gibt
um dieses ding hier
gedrückt halten um es auch schon zu
zumachen dann schauen wir einmal das
kommt red zimmer an wir haben hier links
irgendwann irgendwas zu entdecken wir
haben hier rechts im kleinen safe und
bedienelemente ein spiegel
lüftungsschächte und ansonsten ist dass
das zimmer ich glaube ich kann jetzt
auch nicht mehr so laut reden weil
überall um mich rum liegen natürlich
auch andere leute ansonsten haben wir
lichtschalter für den spiegel
lichtschalter wir hier oben einmal
lüftung für die belüftung vom gesamten
hotelzimmer dann haben wir ein usb
stecker zum laden hier haben wir
bedienelemente bei denen ich noch lernen
muss sie zu nutzen einen wecker
natürlich haben wir erzeugt ein mal
dabei und hier auf der linken seite
irgendwas bei dem es noch nicht weiß was
genau ist ein tisch
ok also ich hätte vieles hier in diesem
hotelzimmer gebraucht aber ein tisch
weil sich jetzt nicht aber vielleicht
werde ich noch herausfinden wofür das
gut ist bevor wir das ganze aber jetzt
ausführlich testen ich sage wie viel das
gekostet wie sich das bett anfühlt ob
ich hier gut schlafen werde ob genug
platz da ist und allgemein wiso mein
eindruck ist wenn wir als aller erstes
mal die sanitäranlagen abchecken weil es
vermutlich so einer der wichtigsten
sachen bei hotels gerade bei günstigen
oder klein mottet auf dem weg ins baden
musste ich als allererstes mal an meinen
schrank meinen schrank ist in diesem
fall ein spind den jeder gast zugewiesen
bekommt um nicht das gesamte gepäck in
der er schon kleinen kapsel haben zu
müssen von dort aus direkt ins bad
erster eindruck ganz gut ich werde
natürlich gleich wieder die uv lampe
auspacken und dann schauen wir uns das
hier mal genauer an aber an und für sich
ist halt alles sind nicht neu das ist
keine gemeinschaftsdusche oder irgendwie
sowas das ist doch ein absoluter traum
und jetzt werde ich erst mal gut
natürlich durfte der uv test nicht
fehlen
hotels die vor getestet habe hatten
einen am zimmer angeschlossenes bleibt
das offensichtlich nur von dem ein gast
des zimmers benutzen also habe ich
erstmal nicht mehr viel von der
sauberkeit erwartet das bad wird
natürlich nicht jedes mal nachnutzung
gereinigt also deutlich schwieriger
sauber zeiten am waschbecken habe ich
angefangen zu suchen um zu meiner
überraschung nur sehr vereinzelt sprung
gefunden und auch die dusche war bis auf
die armatur komplett sauber aus die
toilette als königsdisziplin der bar
tests hat sich dem quasi tadellos
angeschlossen niemand hat lust auf dem
dreck ins bad zu kommen und daher kann
ich mir vorstellen dass tatsächlich
einfach von jedem gast darauf geachtet
wird und quasi so ein unausgesprochenes
gesetz ist dass man so verlässt wie man
es vorgefunden hat einen ziemlich sauber
und deutlich besser als ich mir
vorgestellt hätte
so also ich hab mir jetzt ja alles
einmal angeguckt ich war duschen wir
haben uns das bad gemeinsam angeguckt
ich habe mich ein bisschen mit der
kapsel vertraut gemacht und an und für
sich muss ich sagen ist das ein bomben
konzept dann hat alles was man braucht
natürlich ist nichts wo man vielleicht
eine woche urlaub machen geht in der
stadt also dann würde ich vielleicht
doch zu einem richtigen hotel greifen
aber für eine nacht oder wenn man super
minimalistisch ist dann ist das
vielleicht sogar länger möglich und
wirklich extrem gut das einzige was mich
ein bisschen stört ist tatsächlich die
ausstattung der matratze also die
kapseln sind glaube ich nicht so dicht
deswegen habe ich auch gerade eben
ziemlich viel mit voiceover gemacht weil
ich glaube dass mich halt meine
kompletten nachbarn hören wenn ich
dieses video moderiere und die matratze
ist nicht besonders dick ich würde sagen
so 5 cm das ist okay wie gesagt das
konzept ist für mich perfekt für eine
nacht lang will ich nicht aufwenden das
muss ich schon sagen vielleicht versuche
ich mich aber auch und die matratze wird
deutlich entspannter wenn man nur ein
paar stunden liegt deswegen lege ich
mich jetzt hin werde das ganze mal
testen werde eine nacht geschlafen und
dann gibt's morgen die bewertung und
auch die auflösung was ich hier für eine
nacht in diesem kleinsten teil
deutschlands gezahlt das ding ist ich
glaube ich kann es auch nicht so richtig
entscheiden wenn man jetzt so mega bock
auf japan kram hat und so dumm sich das
anhört wenn man jetzt mehr so gamer teig
beat ist wenn man leicht zum monte
angehaucht ist was farben und näher am
kramer angeht dann nimmt man das hier
wahrscheinlich einfach nochmal komplett
an das war für mich ist das so ein
bisschen zu steril und so ich bin da
nicht so megatoll irgendwie das geht
nicht so in die richtung ist so eckig
kantig ich habe irgendwie das gefühl in
einem lied of legends
eingesperrt zu sein es ist mir so ein
bisschen zu
weiß ich nicht wenn das hier jetzt alles
aus holz wäre ein bisschen dunkler ein
bisschen wärmeres licht dann würde ich
das einfach ein bisschen meister finden
das ist mir super sticky irgendwie desto
länger in der kapsel war desto mehr kam
es mir so vor als wäre das ein fertiges
konzept also habe ich mich als ich
wieder zu hause war mal auf die suche
gemacht ob man diese kapsel hotels
einfach so fertig kaufen kann und
tatsächlich für knapp 500 dollar kann
man die einfach so bei alibaba bestellen
und warum man dann nicht zur holz
variante greift die man ebenso quasi
dasselbe geld auf alibaba bestellen kann
kann ich nicht verstehen aber
möglicherweise wäre das ja sogar eine
idee die man vielleicht irgendwann
umsetzen könnte so gute nacht
bewertungen sucht sag ich mal vorweg es
war ein absoluter traum also tatsächlich
ist hat eine menge spaß gemacht sie
macht an und für sich ein cooles konzept
alles wunderbar aber es ist immer an
sich hat mir nicht gefallen das licht zu
hell das licht zu weist die matratze zu
dünn und nicht besonders gut geschlafen
anderen für sich aber nur cool
experience 5 und css ist gab nicht viel
zusammen die bedienung war besetzt es
war alles wunderbar hier wurde alles
gezeigt ich habe hier bekommen alles
bestens 19 aber eben auch nicht perfekt
verpflegung muss ich ganz ehrlich sein
ich habe kein snack automaten oder
ähnliches gesehen da habe ich auch kein
restaurant erwartet ich muss dieses mal
auslassen weil ich es wirklich nicht
mehr sagen kann ich habe es vergessen
und ich habe auch nichts aufgenommen
sauberkeit definitiv ein punkt der mich
überrascht hat neun von zehn das bad war
wunderbar die kapsel war wunderbar und
alles bestens lage einen punkt denen
leute in den kommentaren sich in diese
bewertung mit rein gewünscht haben wir
waren am spittelmarkt in berlin direkt
mit diesen großen coca cola gebäude ist
es keine traumlage also man geht jetzt
nicht raus und lässt ihn geschehen aber
man geht raus ist eine hauptstraße kommt
überall sogar schnell hin 7 prozent
preis ein absoluter traum ich habe für
diesen 831 euro bezahlt und das ist
wirklich spot on genau da wo ich das
hotel wo ich dieses zimmer sehe wenn man
jetzt eine nacht irgendwo hinfährt für
einen 30
man zieht ein absoluter traum freie
szene
das hier ist die finale bewertung
vergesst nicht dass sie dir zu leiten
hat euch gefallen hat den kanal zu
abonnieren wenig erfolgende videos
verpassen wollt wir sehen uns wieder
wenn ich ein verrücktes aber ein sehr
gutes oder ein sehr schlechtes hotel in
nächster zeit test macht es gut
[Musik]
mal spaßig gelaufen dass wir noch in
berlin